لم تعدوا الحروب بين الدول الكبرى اذ
اندلعت تدور بشكل التقليدي في عصرنا
الحالي استبدلت الصواريخ والاسلحه
والدبابات بالتكنولوجيا المتقدمه لياخذ
التخريب الالكتروني والهجمات السيبرانيه
حيزا كبيرا في اي صراع مقبل قد يندلع
لاسيما بين الصين والولايات المتحده فوسط
التوتر المتصاعد بين البلدين حذرت
المخابرات الامريكيه من خطط صينيه للقيام
بعمليات الكترونيه عدوانيه ضد اهداف
عسكريه داخل البلاد في حال توقعت بكين
معركه كبيره ومشيكه مع الولايات المتحده
لكن التهديد الحقيقي تجلى بالفعل في شكل
استثمارات صينيه ضخمه يقول خبراء امريكيون
انها جمعتها بهدف السماح لقراصنه صينيين
لاستهداف وتعطيل البنى التحتيه الامريكيه
مثل خطوط الانابيب والسكك الحديديه في حال
نشوب صراع بين الجانبين يذكر خلال الاشهر
الماضيه ارتفعت بالفعل حده الاتهامات
الامريكيه لبكين بشن حملاتي تجسس بمختلف
الاشكال والوسائل على مرافق امريكيه حساسه
على الرغم من ان واشنطن اكدت مرارا انها
اتخذت وتتخذ كافه الاحتياطات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات